- Matelas, sofas, autres meubles
et débris en tous iges de la joe
des déménagements étaient
nombreux, dans les quartiers
de Québec.
excusez l'expression,
dégueula
- Non, bien, je m'y attendais,
là, les déménagements,
un petit peu plus long
qu'à l'habitude, peut-être.
- Si, sur les trottoirs,
il reste encore du travail à
d'aide aux locataires, le boulot
est encore plus colossal.
SÉBASTIEN OLIVIER, dir., Office
municipal d'habitation de Québec
- En ce samedi, bien, on répond
peuvent survenir. Il y en a
encore une qui vient tout juste
de surgir ce matin, une dame
qui se retrouvait sans logement
en ce moment même.
- À l'Office municipal
d'habitation de Québec,
on soutient que 55 ménages
se retrouvent toujours
sans logis. L'organisme avait
reçu 554 demandes, c'est plus
du double par rapport
à l'an dernier.
- C'est clair qu'il y a de p
en plus de gens qui ont
de la difficulté à trouver
des logements abordables
sur le marché locatif de Québec.
Ça, c'est une évidence.
- Et la situation ue
partout dans la province,
alors qu'au moins 600 ménages
n'ont toujours pas trouvé
de logement.
C'est à Drummondville
qu'ils sont le plus nombreux.
En contrepartie, ils sont
118 à Montréal.
VÉRONIQUE LAFLAMME, FRAPRU
- Il faut le dire,
ce chiffre-là, c'est la pointe
de l'iceberg, c'est un pâle
reflet de la réalité.
Dans les derniers jours, on a vu
plusieurs ménages locataires,
finalement, choisir des options
qui en étaient pas vraiment,
des parents qui habitent
dans les logements beaucoup
trop petits pour leur famille.
- Cette réalité est également
observée par d'autres organismes
qui rappellent par ailleurs
que trouver un logègle
pas tous les problèmes.
NICOLE DIONNE,
coordonnatrice, BAIL
- Là, on commence à avoir
des appels et des
de locataires qui ont pris
des logements, mais dont
les logements ne sont pas
conformes, donc les travaux
ne sont és, le ménage
n'a pas été fait. Donc, souvent,
ils vont arriver dans des
logements en mauvais état.
- Le FRAPRU compte interpeller
les partis politiqis politiqis s
lors de la prochaine campagne
électorale pour qu'ils
s'engagent à financer 50 000
logements sociaux sur cinq ans.
is-Simon L